Cody Longo an actor known for his work
on Days of Our Lives has died he was 34
years old
[Music]
TMZ reports that Longo's body was found
on Wednesday in Austin Texas
his wife was at work couldn't get a hold
of him and called police to check on the
actor officers responded and kicked it
down Longo's door when he didn't answer
so far no cause of death has been
released but according to the outlet
there are suspicion he died from an
alcohol relapse according to a family
member he struggled with alcohol abuse
and went to rehab last year
the actor was a TV regular with roles on
shows like secrets and lies brothers and
sisters and Make It or Break It on the
big screen he starred in Piranha 3D and
the 2009 remake of Fame I'm really
really excited it's going to be a great
entertaining film you know lots of
energy and I'm really excited Longo was
also an avid musician
sharing his performances on social media
[Music]
just fine
go is survived by his wife and their
three children
[Music]